para el 20 de febrero de 2023 fue fijado
el inicio de un nuevo juicio por la
presunta violación sexual de una ex
asesora política del parlamento federal
de Australia después de que se descubrió
que uno de los miembros del Jurado
accedió a documentos que no formaban
parte del proceso esto obligó al
tribunal anular este juicio tras 12 días
de procesos judicial los jurados no
habían alcanzado un veredicto y seguían
reuniéndose para tomar una decisión en
el proceso que comenzó a principios de
octubre el exasesor del partido liberal
Bruce lerman fue acusado de violar el 22
de marzo de 2019 a su antigua compañera
Brittany higgins en el despacho de la
entonces ministra de industrias de la
defensa linda Reynolds tras su denuncia
se convirtió en un símbolo de múltiples
protestas contra abusos sexuales en
ambientes laborales y despertó fuertes
críticas contra el entonces Primer
Ministro de Australia Scott Morrison por
supuestamente haber minimizado la
gravedad del caso al conocer la decisión
del tribunal de citar un nuevo juicio
con un nuevo Jurado
Que el sistema judicial ha fallado
durante mucho tiempo enfrentar
resultados a las víctimas de agresión
sexual Bruce lerman ha negado las
acusaciones en su contra y de ser
hallado culpable en el juicio podría
enfrentar una sentencia de hasta 12 años
de prisión